welcome everybody my name is Shawn hi my
name is Dave hi my name is Kevin we're
engineers in the Android TV team and we
all work in the Leanback library just
few years back development on TV was
considered difficult exclusively
available to TV manufacturers but times
have changed now and TVs are starting to
evolve at the hands of developers what's
considered a black box running some
archaic software is now running our
familiar Android OS if you know how to
build apps for Android you're already
ready to build as for TV Leanback is a
recommended library for building apps on
TV and today we'll show you how you can
use Leanback library to build some
amazing experiences on TV when building
up for TV year to keep in mind users are
already used to interacting with TV for
a long time the central guiding
principle when building fo TV is to
strike a balance between consistency and
flexibility that is you want to empower
the developer to build unique
experiences while at the same time
maintains consistency across apps
thereby eliminating the need for users
to learn to music learn to use new apps
and if you think about it Android phones
and TVs are not that different they're
both part by the same Android OS but
they're two key differences that you
should keep in mind when building apps
one TVs don't support touchscreen and
second users are usually seated few feet
behind the TV as such the navigation
model for TV is quite different usually
you can go top down left right from any
given point in the next 45 minutes we'll
walk you to different components that
comes with Leanback library the features
that we have added to those components
and some of the other underutilized
features of existing components the
Leanback provides the basic building
blocks for UI it comes with support for
cards rows list of rows actions grids
fragments using these basic building
blocks you can build complex UI
hierarchies but not just basic building
blocks it also makes heavy use of
transition to guide the
user through your flow now no matter
what app you're building you'd want to
display content in a way that's
intuitive and easily accessible lean
Mac's answer to this is browse fragment
it displays content in a set of rows it
consists of three things it has the
headers fragment to the left which has
the navigation menu arranged in a
vertical list it is the title bar to the
top which displays your branding
information in a row and there's a rose
fragment to the right which displays
your content in a set of rows now browse
prepping does a lot of heavy lifting for
you
it runs the transition it takes care of
the coordination between the headers
fragment and the rows fragment it also
shows and hides the table view at
appropriate times it is pretty
comprehensive but just few lines of code
you can get up and running but you don't
want to build a generic app you know
build something that is unique something
that is character something that people
can spot from a distance
next we'll walk you through different
techniques you can employ to make your
app unique but before this is an example
implementation of browse fragment you
can see but just few lines of code give
a functional app all you have to do is
set the branding information with a said
batch drawable call then you load the
data and populate the data and set the
data in the code by calling the set
adapter method and finally you said your
listeners that's all you need to do in
order to have a functional app one
caveat to keep in mind is if you want to
run the entrance transition you want to
call it the first time you go into your
app we'll talk about this a little more
detail in a later slide remember I
mentioned headers fragmented spheres to
the left has the list of navigation
menus that is great but what if you
wanted to group your navigation menus
for this the latest version of Leanback
library has support for two new rows
section row and divider row section row
which is the title marks the beginning
of a group of navigation menu and
divided robots the ending of the group
the way to add them is as simple as when
you're adding data to your adapter you
know inject those rows in the same order
that there
years that you want them to appear in
the headers fragment that's it now
headers fragment is an optional
component you can either enable it or
disable it and by doing so your app will
have a very different look and feel to
it
the way to do that is by calling set
header state function with either header
set enabled a disabled parameter leaned
back in an effort to separate styling
from logic makes heavy use of Android
track theming every component in lean
back comes with its own theme now if you
want to customize the component all you
have to do is create a style that
extends from the theme and override the
attributes that you care about here is
an example of a browse fragment it
doesn't even look like a classical
browse fragment here we've upset the
content to the bottom of the page by
using a combination of margin top and
padding start you see the power of team
is without changing a single line of
code just by overwriting two attributes
we can give a different look and feel to
your app Leanback comes with the
extensive set of styles and themes we
encourage you to take a look at the
style file the shifts will lean back and
see what makes for you do sense for you
to override the title view which appears
on the top of browse fragment is ready
just for your branding information but
the classical title view displays a
search icon a title or a logo now that
is great
but what if you wanted to display your
own custom view the latest version of
lean back supports custom title view the
first thing you want to do is create a
custom view second you want to create a
tight layout file which uses your custom
view and then you want to override the
Browse subtle view layout property with
the location of your layout file as soon
as you do that browse program will pick
up the layout you created and rendered
that in the top section of browse
fragment as a final step though you will
have to implement the title view adapter
provided interface the title the adapter
interface is what browse fragment uses
to communicate with your fragment
it it's used to tell your view to show
or hide itself Leanback comes with a
default implementation of title view
which implements the table view adapter
we encourage you to take a look at the
source code and see how that's
implemented we talk to a lot of
developers TV app developers and there
was a growing consensus about the need
for further customization a brass
fragment is great
it displays item in a set of rows but
what if you wanted to do something more
custom maybe you have a fragment for
your phone app that you want to
repurpose for your TV app or maybe you
wanna have a completely different
representation of your media items for
this use cases we introduce what's
called Pedro which is a subclass of RO
with Pedro you can have your custom
fragment rendered inside browse fragment
typically developers will pair the
header item with list row which
represents a collection of items now
browse repin internally maintains a
registry which Maps each row type to a
corresponding Factory in this specific
case we map the list row two rows
fragment which knows how to render each
individual item in a set of cards in the
horizontal grid for page rows you want
to pair each header item with the page
row and then register your factory with
browse fragment then as soon as browse
fragment sees a Pedro is going to look
into its registry find out your factory
and then using the factory it's going to
instantiate your fragment and then
render that in the main content area
with that being said we'll jump into a
demo and see this in action
thank you sure
so here I will demo a new sample app
which we develop for Android TV we just
open source this app yesterday and the
URL to github will be provided at the
end of this presentation for the demo
purposes here we are using the Android
TV emulator so the home screen of this
app is a browse fragment which consists
of a set of different cards each card
here represents a separate component
between leaned back
I will start off this demo by showing
different examples of custom fragments
this browse fragment consists of four
different custom fragments when I
switched within the roads a different
fragment will be loaded each time the
first fragment displays images in a
vertical grid here for example I can
navigate images across different roads
the next row is an example of a standard
Rose fragment that is embedded between a
custom fragment here you'll see several
icons that are organized into multiple
roads the next example shows settings
the settings icons embedded within two
rows and finally we have an example
where a webview is embedded between a
custom fragment
unfortunately the Wi-Fi connectivity is
not very great here so it's a part that
requires network will not play but just
just in case you know there's gonna be a
full cool page displayed on the right so
this example showed that we can embed
any custom fragment inside the Browse
fragment you might have also noticed
that we have a title view on the top you
can embed any custom widget in here for
example here we are using a custom
layout with a textview and an analog
clock
thanks.thanks give up so the Democrats
are not in favor for us trust me the web
page will load if you embed the web view
inside the custom pregnant anyway so we
talked about custom fragment now we'll
show you how you can wire your custom
fragment inside browse fragment and then
we'll show you some snippets of code
remember I mentioned browse fragment has
an internal registry which make which
Maps each row type 2 corresponding
Factory now when you supply a page row
it's gonna look into the registry find
the factory for corresponding to the
page row and use that Factory to
instantiate your fragment
now your fragment must implement main
fragment adapter provider this is the
interface that brought seven uses to get
hold of main fragment adapter you may
ask what is that adapter well mainframe
eight adapter is the interface that
browse driving uses to communicate with
your fragment for events such as like
I'm studying the animation or I'm
running animation sera the animation is
over things like that now there is
another optional component called
mainframe in ROS adapter this is a
special case that only is only used by
ROS fragment this is used by browse
fragment to communicate ro based events
so that it can maintain synchronous it
can sync both the headers fragment and
ROS fragment now Rose fragment comes
with the implementation for this adapter
will encourage you to take a look at the
source code and see how that's
implemented now these are all different
ways browser stripping can talk to your
fragment but what if your program wanted
to talk to browse fragment for that we
provide fragment host which represents
all possible actions then your fragment
is allowed to take on browse fragment
now let's take a look at some code the
first thing you want to do if you want
to implement custom fragment is
implement fragment factory all you have
to do is override one method create
fragment now remember the data that's
passed in to create fragment is the
currently selected row which is either
Pedro or subclass of Pedro so you can
type as that to a Pedro and then inspect
the data in there and return the
appropriate instance of the fragment
once you do that then you want to
register your factory with browse
fragment and we recommend you do that in
the constructor of your class next you
wanna implement the main fragment
adapter provider to return an instance
of main fragment adapter this is the
interface that browse fragment uses to
communicate with your fragment as a
final step you have to implement the
main fragment adapter now browse
fragment comes with a default
implementation of men mainframe in
adapter but if that doesn't satisfy your
need you can extend from it
and over at the behavior that we care
about the general pattern for
implementing this is the adapter should
act like a pass-through tier fragment
here we override the set entrance trait
set entrance transition state method and
then call back into the fragment the
fragment in turn based on the boolean
value sets the visibility of the
individual views so the transition
system can notice the difference and run
the appropriate transition it's as
simple as that so that's a lot of odd
custom fragment now let's talk about
cards cards are another key component of
the in BEC library one of the key
classes that comes with Leanback is
called image card view that's used to
render cards it consists of two areas it
has the image area with a special image
on top and as the info at the bottom
which displays your content such as
title and description and an optional
icon now whatever app you're building if
you're displaying me a audio video or
whatever media you want to display
it'll be displayed in cards but just
because you're rendering everything in
cars doesn't mean all your cards will
have to look alike you can have
different types of card in the same
application and the way to do that is by
creating a style that extends from image
card view style and overriding the
attribute that you care about one such
interesting attribute is the LV image
card view type this controls what
content gets rendered in the card it
takes four possible values title content
icon right an icon left and these are
not mutually exclusive
here are three cards with three
different values for this attribute the
one on the Left displays the title in
the info area the one in the middle the
space title and the content and one the
very right the space title content and
the icon on the left you can see just by
creating new styles you can have
different representation for your cards
another interesting attribute is card
type this controls the positioning of
info area in relation to your image area
it has three possible values info under
info over and mean only and here are
three cards which uses three different
values for this attribute the first one
this is the default configuration and
this is the info area underneath the
image view the second one info over
lines of the info area with the bottom
of the image card so info area appears
to be on top of the card and the final
one mean only hides the info area
altogether in this case you're free to
supply any custom layout you want in
specific case we are using a custom
layout which displays the content to the
right of the image now once you create
your style there are two more steps you
need to need to do in order to create
custom cards first you know create a
theme and overrate the image card view
style attribute with the style you just
created
you can choose to over add other
attributes if you want to once you do
that then you can instantiate your image
card view and use the theme you just
created using context team wrapper
that's it that's all you need to do in
order to create custom cards now there
are other attributes they can override
you can play around with and see if that
kind of like gives you a little more
control over the look and feel of the
cards will encourage you to take a look
at the style files and see what makes
sense for you to override now just in
case image card view doesn't satisfy
your need you can also look at base card
view which is the base class for image
card view and gives you control over
both the layout as well as the content
that is rendered on the card but that
being said we'll jump into a quick demo
and show you different kinds of cards
next I'm gonna demo different types of
cards here this browse fragment shows
several variations of image card view
and base card view the first row we have
image card view where the title spans a
single line here we see some examples of
this car the second row displays image
card view but the title spans to a line
and the rating icon is to the left the
next row is an example of image card
views where all the components are
present we have the image view on top
the title the rating icon to the left
and the content which is the price here
to the right we have more variations of
image card views in the next couple of
rows but if these image card views don't
satisfy your needs and you need to have
more control over the card appearance
here are some advanced examples in this
rule we have examples of base card view
with the main only card type this one
uses a custom layout with a content
placed to the right of the image the
next row is another example of base card
view with the main only card type here
however instead of the image on the top
you are using a text field we have more
variations of in image card view in the
next row and finally we have image card
view where we have provided the
unfocused change listener you notice
that the background changes as a card
receives focus thank you
Thanksgiving so we talked a lot about
like browse fragment and custom fragment
and carbons next dick is going to talk
about the best practices for entrance
transition and also talk about some of
the other components in lean back
Thank You chef animations so prospect
pinch is usually inside the first
activity of your app which might takes a
while to load data so user will see a
blank screen when they try to be loaded
if you upload data row by row item by
item user might see multiple screen
updates during data being loaded to
solve these problems
prospect mint has a best practice called
entrance transition this is where not
the less known feature of linkback
library I'm going to talk about today
entrance transition gives user a visual
feedback that the that the data is being
loaded as you can see there the spinning
spinning with spinning icon there once
the data finish loading prospect mint we
are slide content from two sites next
commands go to a demo in today
so before we go into the details of the
interns transition here I will showcase
an example interns transition in lean
back I will play the Browse fragment
here you'll notice that we have a
sliding transition happening from the
opposite sides the headers fragment is
sliding from the left and the rows
fragment is sliding from the right to
capture this transition once more I will
play this demo once again and here is
how it looks browse fragment not only
supports in trans transition for ROS
fragment but any custom fragments can
also take advantage of that for instance
here when I open an any custom fragment
you'll notice that once the data loading
is complete we'll have similar interns
transition the ROS fragment is sliding
from the left and the custom fragment is
sliding from the right I will play this
once more and with that dig we'll cover
the details of interesting additions so
let's take a look how your app can use a
trans transition this is the two steps
process first your aapko prepare
entrance transition in Europe your
fragment on create this tells browse
fragment don't show anything yet until I
tell you to do so later internally
browse fragments will hide the content
on the left and hide all the views
inside the main area the next step once
your app loads all your data you call
this start entrance transition this is a
signal tells browse fragment that all my
data is ready now you can start
animation if you are just using
classical browse fragment is playing
list of roles all you need to know is
prepare entrance transition and start
entrance transition course but what if
your app has your own custom fragment to
make your custom apartment part of the
entrance transition you need to
implement this method inside
the main fragment adapter when prospect
meant prepare a chest tradition your
caused into this method third annual to
hide all the individual views inside
their custom fragment when prospect
means not the inhalation it what tells
you to show all individuals through the
same method with a different parameter
value now we also have these three
callbacks these are optional because
Rose fragments internally it uses
research review you might know that
research reveal an omission cannot be
run together with transition an
emissions so the Rouge fragment listen
to this Comex it disabled an omission in
our tradition prepare it disable the
layout when transition started and it
ring a bald layout and renewable and
emission when transition finishes
remember these are optional only if your
custom fragments is also using research
review you need to listen to these
comics now because prospect meant needs
to hide and show views inside your
fragment so your custom fragment needs
to let prospect man know your view has
been created you're doing so by calling
notified via created on the fragment
host object
and also because your custom fragment
usually have your own data and which can
take extra time to load this data is not
the same data inside the Browse fragment
adapter so remember you need to call
start ancients transition to tell
prospect meant that all the data inside
the browser adapter is ready so here
your custom fragment need to call
additional method notified it already to
tell the bra fragment and the data
inside your custom fragment is ready and
then prospect meant can do the
transitions so to put all the pieces
together we have the sequence diagram
first you have course prepare a trans
transition in concrete then browse
fragment will hide all the header views
and don't show anything the main area
then prospect man starts to loading data
once it allows the Pedro it will create
your fragment from the factory next once
all the data inside the prospect wind is
loaded because start entrance transition
but we cannot start and wishing yet
because your fragment is not ready
so prospect mint is waiting for your
fragment to call notify view created so
the prospect pants cause set entrance
transition state force this tells your
custom fragment to to hide all the views
inside your fragment at the last step
once your fragment load all data you
call notified it already and
broad-spectrum calls sent entrance
tradition stay true which tells you to
show all the wheels then we can start
animation
so we have talked a lot about
prospecting today and night in the next
section I'm going to talk about some
other fragments in about libraries if
your app wants to interact with user on
TV we recommend you to use this guy
disturb fragment this is a UX design for
user sitting 10 feet away from TV so the
screen is very simple as you can see to
the left we call it a guidance area this
is the read only area that prompts the
user what user can do on the screen to
the right is a list of guided actions
this is the area that user can interact
with
next humans go to the quick demo
so say you you want to rent a movie here
I will show you an example work follow
up doing so using guided asta fragment
cadets a fragment here presents the user
with a sequence of fragments at each
step it will ask the user to take a set
of actions it would also make it easy
for the user to navigate back and forth
across all the fragments so I will start
off by choosing the rent HD version of
the movie here but let's say at this
point I change my mind and I want to
rent the HD version of the movie instead
I can easily navigate back to the
previous screen and select the HD
version of the movie here here we see an
example of a gutted surf fragment with a
drop down action I can either choose one
of the existing credit cards where I've
entered before or if I want I can add a
new credit card in a new fragment screen
here we see an example of an editable
action where I can enter my credit card
number so I will go ahead and enter my
real credit card number
and once I'm done it with that I'm gonna
pick a valid expression date this is an
example of the date picker widget
provided by Leanback you'll notice that
once the information I entered about my
credit card is validated the okay button
is enabled next I will hit the ok button
and I will be directed back to the
previous screen where I left off next I
will choose the rent and after the
processing is complete I will be
presented in a foreknowledge screen but
I can start watching the movie you'll
see that once I select the watch now got
to the SIP fragment will close all the
existing fragments and a new book will a
new video will start playing
unfortunately again the video will not
play here but live it is it's gonna be a
really nice video and with that take
we'll cover the details upgraded cell
fragments thank you
so to create your credits defragment you
extend from the base class Callister
fragment and override these three
methods first you provide guidance which
is the read-only where to the left
second you provide a list of credit
actions for the user and then you
respond to user actions and do something
for your app a credit action it has an
ID which is identified for your program
to know which guided action user has
interact with it has a title and
description
so the basic credit action is a click
only action you can also make the guy
Direction like a radio or checkbox you
can make the title editable or you can
make the description editable but not
post at the same time
here are some at the mouth examples the
date picker and a list of subjects which
implement the drop-down list feature to
use the canister fragment you have two
choices
your either start the workflow in a
separate activity or you can start a
flow in your existing activity in the
first approach you call others route in
activity on create remember you only do
this will see the instance is now if
your activity is restoring from see the
instance the fragment manager will
automatically restore fragment for you
so you don't add a duplicate fragment in
this case if you have don't wanna use an
activity you wanna do everything in
fragments that's why you can add the
Cadi step on top of your existing
content
to not get between the fragments you
usually do this by responding to user
actions and call add function with the
new fact fragment name that you were to
not get to the fragments are added using
back stack entry so if you user click
back button on the remote he will be
ticked back to the previous screen but
sometimes you app wants to go multiple
step back you can call this poor back
step with the specific class name of the
fragment finally if you want to finish
your flow you call finish ready step
fragments this will close all the
predecessor fragments and if your flow
was started in a separate activity it
will also close the activity settings so
in Andrew n we have redesigning you
androidtv
Settings app it's now like a side panel
laying on top of other content if you
want your app also to use the same
feature you can use link back Settings
fragment this fragment starts with a
header view followed by a list of
reference objects each preference object
has icon title a summary optionally the
purpose object had been better widget
inside it in this case it's a switch
widget
so I'm not going into the details of
settings fragment but you are welcome to
take a look at the sample code in a
showcase earth
playback fragment flip a Kalevala
fragment when you have tried to play
audio or max a podcast then you might
use playback overlay control fragment
this fragment usually starts with a
playback in choose roll with upcoming
release we provide a support for you to
rendering a media item roll a media term
row has two parts to the left is a media
item details it includes the track
number the sound title and duration to
the right there are multiple clickable
actions to use this feature you have
extends from abstract media item
presenter which is responsible for
rendering a row you overwrite unbind
media details your media item can be any
class it doesn't need to be like a
subclass of row object so you kept the
values from your some object and feel
that data into the view holder
optionally if you wanna support the
actions to the right of the media item
details you can implement this provider
interface and provide a list of actions
next I'm gonna demo the playback oil a
fragment this fragment comes with a set
of new features which will be available
in the upcoming Android end release once
I open this fragment the first song will
start
okay so the top section of this fragment
is the playback media player and the
bottom section is the media item rows
all the individual components within
this fragment can be customized through
themes and styling for instance the
developers can specify the information
about the currently playing song the
primary set of actions such as play or
part the secondary stop action suggests
thumbs-up or thumbs-down
and on the bottom we have the media item
rows each media item row can consist of
information such as the title of the
song the duration the the artist and
they are followed with a set of optional
actions for the actions here we are
having the add to the playlist button
and a favorite button action in lean
back we provide listener hooks for
either selecting or clicking on each one
of these individual components so let's
say I want to listen to a song I can do
that by clicking on the media item
details for that song
like
that concludes our demo section
so you've got a lot of grants today
first we talked about how easy it is for
you to get up and running with just few
lines of code using browse fragment let
me show you different techniques you can
employ to give you an absent character
let me show you how you can plug in your
custom fragment inside browse fragment
they show you how to use different kinds
of cards in the same application we
talked about the best practices for
running entrance transition we also show
you how you can use guided step fragment
to walk a user to a workflow we showed
you the newly styled Settings fragment
and the newly redesigned playback
fragment hopefully you get a sense how
Leanback tries to provide comprehensive
set of components for supporting
different use cases on TV that being
said we're always interested in
listening to developer comments feedback
suggestion feature request we can't wait
to see what are you going to build with
the new Leanback library thank you very
much for coming
before we go into Q&A couple things on a
call-out our sandbox series right around
the corner so please come by say hello
and and see this in action if you wanna
and the second is if you guys are
watching remotely then we have a
developer community and Google+ please
join the community and we'll be sharing
helpful tips and also helping you solve
any problems if you run into there and
we have the showcase app which is
available on github for cloning please
play around with it if you have any
questions suggestions let us know
hey I have a question about webview
in the beginning pretty sure that you
know plug in the webview right but as I
remember the guidelines you said to
avoid using the webview because TV is
not from web so it's something changing
here or I think you're absolutely right
we don't recommend using webview there
was an example aim to display the
flexibility of custom fragment and what
you can do with it but you're absolutely
right we should be using webview inside
to be up any other questions
yeah we'll be around in the sandbox area
please come by
you